SEBASTIEN MAROTTE:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
--and switch into English
to please welcome Ulku Rowe.
Thank you very much.
ULKU ROWE: Good
morning, everyone.
It's great to be here in
Paris, City of Lights, la Ville
Lumieres.
When I was getting ready
to come here from New York,
I wondered how
Paris got that name.
So I Googled.
I found out two things.
The first is did you
know that in 1860s there
were 56,000 gas lamps
illuminating the streets
and boulevards of Paris?
The second why reason is
even more interesting.
Paris got its name, the City
of Lights, because of the role
that it played in
the 18th century
in the Age of Enlightenment.
So I can't think
of a better place
to be talking about the
next set of revolutions that
will bring in a different
age of enlightenment,
the age of innovation and
digital transformation.
Now we're living
in exciting times.
It's a time of enormous change.
We are living through a change
in our lives, in our society,
and in business.
And all of this is happening
at an unprecedented pace.
Now one of the places that
we can see this change
is in the Fortune 500.
The Fortune 500 was
first set up in 1955
with an initial set
of 500 companies.
Only 60 years later in 2014,
only 61 of those companies
remain.
Now if you are one
of the 439, that
is a pretty scary statistic.
And from that very
first 500 companies,
nobody remembers, unless
you're a car enthusiast,
the American car
maker Studebaker.
But we have welcomed Tesla.
We don't remember Collins
Radio, but Netflix is here.
Companies are going
out of business.
Companies are being acquired
and new companies are coming in.
And it's happening faster
and faster every day.
So what is driving
all this change?
What's happening?
What is the difference between
organizations that fail
and those that thrive?
And of course the
answer is technology.
Technology is everywhere.
And this intersection of
various technology trends,
cloud and mobile and
social and IoT and big
data and machine
learning are having
a profound impact in our
lives and our businesses.
Now before I came to Google,
I had a pretty long career
in financial services.
And we had a we had a
very simple mission.
We were building
systems to enable
efficient, frictionless, safe
and sound financial markets.
Unfortunately though,
doing that meant
we had to spend an
inordinate amount of time
on things like
hardware procurement
and supply chain management
and network set up
and databases and
software upgrades.
Now cloud enables
you to change that.
It enables you to
focus on technology
that differentiates
your business,
and de-focus technology
that does not.
And it doesn't end with cloud.
With mobile and
social, businesses
can reach their
customers, no matter where
they are on the planet.
And it's not just people,
devices as well with
IoT, Internet of Things.
And all these
interactions are now
creating data that can be
processed with big data
and machine learning to turn
into insights and engagement
models with our customers
that we were never
able to do before.
And this is available
to everyone,
no matter how
large or how small.
So it is no longer
about big versus small.
Now it's about the
fast versus the slow.
Companies need to
be faster, they
need to be faster at
identifying customer trends.
And they need to be faster
at responding to market.
They need to be faster
at decision making.
They need to be
faster at everything.
Change is going to come.
The question is are you
going to be an agent of it,
or are you going
to be a casualty?
Now the way to deal with
that changes of course
again through technology.
At Google, we believe that every
company, regardless of its size
or industry, will differentiate
themselves through technology.
And all of that is
centered on data.
So we believe that every company
is or will become a technology
company.
And in this world,
your engineering talent
is your only
sustainable advantage.
So I've been a New
Yorker for 20 years,
but I'm originally from Turkey.
When I was growing up
in Turkey, the quality
of your public transportation
kind of depended
on your proximity to
your fellow passengers.
So if you didn't have money,
buses were super cheap,
but they were packed
like sardines.
And if you had a
little bit more money,
you could get a cab where
you could have the whole car
to yourself, except now you are
at the mercy of your driver.
And I am convinced that
every single driver in Turkey
thinks they're a Formula One
driver, except the safety
and the security.
And in between
these two things we
had what we called
the [TURKISH]..
The literal translation of
that word means stuffed.
It means stuffed.
So these are smaller cars,
usually sedans or minivans.
And they don't have fixed stops,
but they are fixed routes.
And if you want to get on one,
you hail one and they stop.
And if they have room to stuff
another person in, you get in.
So because it's a
smaller car, they're
limited by how many
people they can stuff
by the number of their seats.
So it's only marginally
more expensive than the bus,
but the experience is
much better than the bus.
So that was ride sharing
1.0 the Turkish way.
Now today we're sharing, we're
experiencing ride sharing 2.0
the global away.
Ride sharing companies
are completely
transforming the transportation
industry all over the world.
They are using technology
to completely undermine
the principles or
the assumptions
that the previous business
model was predicated upon.
And it's not just the app that
allows you to hail the car
and know where the car is
and the driver finds you,
it's also things like
availability of the GPS
and maps and voice, which means
that the driver doesn't have
to memorize every road and
every point of interest
that everybody
might want to know.
And it's about being
able to give feedback,
so that you can get a sense of
the credibility of the driver.
So you're not at the
mercy of the Formula One
drivers in Istanbul.
And so this is all
has changed completely
how transportation works.
And it doesn't mean that Uber
or Lyft will be the winners.
It just means that that industry
has been completely changed
and it will never
be the same again.
And most likely the next set
of disruption in that industry
is going to be the self-driving
cars where you won't even
need that cab driver.
This is what we call
digital transformation,
and it's not doing things
just a little bit better,
it is doing things differently.
It is about doing
different things.
Now the question that you
should be asking here today
is what does your digital
transformation look like?
What does that
journey like for you?
And that journey is
not to the cloud.
Cloud is not a destination.
Cloud is a vehicle that gets you
to your digital transformation.
Now as we ask that
question, there
are four things that
you need to think about.
The first is optimization.
How do you optimize
your IT operations?
How do you get out
of the business
of delivering technology
that doesn't differentiate
your business?
Now we say make it our
problem, because you know what?
Delivering infrastructure and
platforms at extreme scale,
with great reliability
and performance,
and with trust and security is
what we do best here at Google.
Second is collaboration.
How do we help you create an
environment in your own shops
that promotes innovation?
And how do we create
an environment
where the whole is greater
than the sum of the pieces?
And it's not just about making
things a little bit faster
and a little bit better, it's
about doing things differently.
It's about doing
different things.
Now we're going to talk
about acceleration.
How can we help you
accelerate your business
with data and machine learning?
And finally, we're going
to talk about partnering,
because that journey to
your digital transformation
doesn't have to be one
that you walk alone.
That partnership starts
with openness for us.
And it's more than
just open source.
It's about flexible
architectures and flexible--
and customer friendly
costing structures.
Now how can we take everything
that makes Google great
and share that with you?
And go beyond that?
How do we co-invest in the
success of your business
with you?
We'll talk about that.
And at Google, it is not
about just infrastructure,
it's about the
collaboration platforms.
It's about being able to
run your applications safe
and securely.
And it's about
data and analytics.
And it's about machine learning.
So during the course of
today's presentations,
we are going to share with
you our thoughts on what
that digital transformation
journey looks like,
and the various
way stations in it.
So let's start
with optimization.
Well, congratulations.
You have made the decision
to move to the cloud.
You've made the decision
to adopt a technology
platform that enables
you to focus on what's
important for your
business to be more
efficient, to
collaborate better,
to innovate faster, be more
agile, be more responsive.
Now how do you pick
your cloud provider?
What factors help
you determine who
is going to be the best partner
in that digital transformation?
Now in my role, I
get to talk to a lot
of C level executives and
IT professionals like you,
and here is what they told me.
Here's what you told me.
You said it's about
reliability, it's
about security, excellent
support, performance,
and cost effectiveness
in that order.
You picked these because
cloud infrastructure is not
a commodity, because the
quality of the infrastructure
that you are going to build
your business on matters.
It makes a big difference.
And these are the things that
actually differentiates us
at Google.
Our ability to run
at planet scale
with great reliability
and performance,
with trust and security,
with excellent partnership
and good price.
We have been building and
operating a planet scale
cloud for a very long time.
Now over the years, we
built seven platforms
with over one
billion users each.
Anyone recognize those logos?
Raise your hand if you have used
any of these products for me?
Raise your hand.
Keep your hand up if
you use them today.
Yeah?
And keep your hand
up if you've use them
since I started talking.
I appreciate the honesty.
Thank you for being customers.
But as we did that along the
way, we learned quite a bit
about running a cloud at scale.
And we learned about security
and reliability and efficiency,
and all the experiences that
you enjoy about Google already.
And it has that same
infrastructure and expertise
that we offer to our
GCP clients so they
can run their
businesses at scale
with reliability and security.
And now today, our
GCP clients are
serving their over one
billion users on GCP.
So how does Google
build reliable systems?
How do we do it?
It's not just one thing.
It's many things.
It's about how we
do data centers.
It's how we think
about networking.
It's about how we build
and deploy software.
We build SRER Site Reliability
Engineering Practice years ago
to be able to run ultra
scalable and reliable systems.
And our engineers over time
have come up with new paradigms
on how to run these
large systems.
And they became with new
ways of introducing change
at high velocity without
compromising from reliability
or performance.
So we literally did
write the book on it.
We took all our experiences
and we put it together,
and we published
it on our website.
And it's free and
available for everyone.
And it is that same
experience that we are now
offering our customers with
our customer reliability
engineering practice,
where we take
our experiences, our
methods, and our frameworks,
and now we share them with you.
What's better than reliability?
It's reliability that doesn't
come with a high price tag.
Indeed, for dollar
for dollar, GCP
provides better
performance value
than any other cloud
provider in the market.
This is from Cloud Spectator's
independent benchmarking
study that was published
earlier this summer.
And a key part of
delivering that performance
is our global premium network.
We run and operate the world's
largest IP data network.
We have dark and light
fiber across every continent
on the planet except
for Antarctica.
We have an undersea
cables across the Atlantic
and the Pacific.
And our data centers don't
connect to just each other
like some competing clouds do.
Our data centers connects to
every single in the world.
Today, about 40% of the
world's entire internet traffic
goes through our network.
We recently introduced a
premium network, in addition
to our already super ultra
fast standard network.
If you need it, it's
about 70% more performant.
Now we pay incredible
amount of attention
to the quality and the
reach of our network.
Why do we do that?
We do that because if you
are a business with customers
all over the planet,
their performance
and your reliability
of that network
is going to be important to you.
The other reason we do
this is for security.
Remember we talked
about the five factors
at the beginning
that was important?
Security was number two.
The reality is the
fewer public internet
transit points you have in
your network, the less likely
are you going to get cyber
attacks because you'll
be eliminating things
like man in the middle,
traffic profiling and
shaping, and surveillance.
A network you control end
to end is inherently safer.
At Google, our ability to
deliver security at scale
is what differentiates us.
Now it used to be that
security was the reason people
didn't move to the cloud.
Today, security is the
reason to move to the cloud.
We believe in defense in depth.
That means that
we embed security
at every layer of our stack.
We custom design and
build our servers
and networking equipment.
We eliminate any
unnecessary parts
that would create
additional vulnerabilities.
We've run proprietary and
hardened operating systems.
And we run software stacks
that we constantly test
and fix for vulnerabilities.
Now above all of
this, we believe
in a very simple philosophy.
We trust nothing.
We believe that if anything
can fail or can be compromised,
it will fail and it
will get compromised.
How far do we take
this philosophy?
Let me introduce you to Titan.
Titan is a custom chip
designed by Google.
We put it on all our
news servers and hardware
into network cards
in our devices.
It allows us to protect the
identity of our machines
by establishing a
hardware with a trust.
It helps us authenticate
the hardware,
and protects against
tampering at the hardware bios
and services level.
Now in Greek mythology,
titans were these big giants
of incredible strength.
Well, Titan packs all of that
in this tiny little chip.
The Titan chip that
you see up there
is smaller than my
fingernail on my pinky.
Now if you are in
the audience today
and you are in one of
the regulated industries,
you're in financial
services or you're
in health care or another
industry, you're saying,
this is great.
It's awesome, but
how about compliance?
How can Google
help us with that?
Well, it is very important
to us to help our clients be
able to use our systems
and sources no matter
which industry or
geography they sit on.
So every year we go
through dozens and dozens
of independent verifications
of our security, privacy,
and compliance controls.
Some examples of them
are appear on the screen,
like our SOC and ISO
certifications, our PCI
compliance, and Privacy Shield.
Now in addition to these
global certifications,
we also provide
local certifications
in individual countries.
As I said, we're committed
to helping our customers meet
their regulatory and policy
demands, no matter where they
are.
Another example of this is the
upcoming European Global Data
Protection Regulation GDPR.
And we are fully
committed to be complying
with it by the time it goes
into effect May of 2018.
We are constantly
innovating in our quest
to find better ways to help
you secure your business.
So today I'm going
to highlight two.
The first one is
identity Aware Proxy.
Remember how I said we
don't trust anything?
One of the things we don't trust
is corporate networks and VPNs.
Now traditional security
relies on VPN and firewalls.
Now the problem with that,
if once a bad actor gets in,
they can do a lot of damage.
So instead, we offer
identity aware proxy
which enables you to
enforce who gets access
to what at the
application layer,
not with the remote
access VPNs and firewalls.
The second one I want
to highlight today
is our data loss prevention API.
Data loss prevention
API lets you
discover PII and
other sensitive data,
and give you an option to be
able to redact or anonymize it.
Now to show us some of
this innovation in action,
I'd like to call up
Francesc Campoy to show
us the power of DLP API.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
ULKU ROWE: Thanks, Francesc
for that wonderful demo.
Now DLP is just one of the
examples of how we help
you secure your businesses.
Now our security
capabilities don't just
end with infrastructure.
They go into our
collaboration platforms
and extend all the way up to our
endpoints and access platforms.
Our global scale access across
the enterprise and our consumer
gives us unprecedented
visibility due to threats.
So let me give you an example.
In Gmail, over one
billion users that we
have in Gmail,
email every minute
we filter out 10
million spam messages.
And we are able to do that
with 99% accuracy thanks
to our machine learning models.
For our Chrome
users, we warn them
of suspected malware
992 times a minute.
And we notify them of
potentially unwanted software
6,000 times.
For our Android users,
we check the health
of 400 million devices daily.
And for six billion
mobile apps, we
check them to make sure
they're not infected.
We protect two billion
mobile phones, tablets,
and other devices that
use Google Safe Browsing
technology.
For our GCP clients,
this means end
to end security all the
way from infrastructure
to endpoints and
access platforms.
Now infrastructure provides the
foundation of your business.
And with the right
cloud partner,
you can optimize
your infrastructure
and make it more reliable, more
secure, and most connected.
Now once you've
done that, we can
help you accelerate
that path to innovation.
And to continue the discussion
into about this new age
of enlightenment, the age of
innovation and transformation,
I would love to call on stage
one of my collaborators, David
Thacker, to talk
about collaboration.
Welcome onstage David.
DAVID THACKER: Thank you
Ulku for the introduction.
Good morning, bonjour.
It's great to be in Paris.
Thank you for coming today.
My name is David Thacker.
I'm a vice president of
product management at Google.
I'm responsible for
our G Suite products.
And I'm based in
our Silicon Valley
headquarters in California.
Today I'm going to
talk about G suite
and how it can transform
the way your company
works, making it much
more collaborative.
So when we think
about the world,
and we think about
the major achievements
and whether it's business or
architecture, or engineering,
collaboration has always
been a central part of that.
So I was looking
today for an example
to highlight that's relevant
to France and to Paris.
So I want to talk
about the Eiffel
Tower, and the
collaboration that
went into making the structure.
I think a lot of people
believe, such as myself,
I had thought that
Gustav Eiffel was
a genius that designed
and created the Eiffel
Tower himself.
But when you study
the history, it's
actually much more complex.
The Eiffel Tower, the original
sketch that you see behind me
was developed by two structural
engineers working together.
In fact, this sketch was
developed by one of them
while he was working at home.
So next time your boss tells
you you can't work from home,
just remind them that sometimes
your most creative elements
come out when you're working
at home, away from the office.
They brought the sketch
into their office,
and they reviewed it
with a few other people,
including their head
of architecture.
The head of architecture
at their firm
said this is a great
structure, but we
need to make it much better.
And so he added his insights.
And as a result, they developed
some other embellishments
such as the
decorative arches you
see at the bottom the Eiffel
Tower, or the glass observatory
that you see on the first floor.
They then took this to Gustav
Eiffel who acquired the patent.
And with a team of 300 people,
came up with the final designs
and constructed the building
over the course of two years.
The final achievement was the
tallest man made structure
in the world at a time in 1889.
And we'd certainly today
think of it as a masterpiece.
Now although that
was 130 years ago,
when you think about the world
of business today and the year
2017, whether your business is
creating life saving medicines
or running a global
shipping company
or advancing telecommunications,
creating electric cars,
all these achievements
would not be
possible without the
collaborative efforts
of your employees
working together.
And employers today
want the best tools
to work together so they
can work more quickly,
so they can be more
productive, and so
they can focus on maximizing
their creative output.
In fact, employees that have the
best tools are happier overall.
And so that's really
why we created G Suite.
G Suite is our
collection of products
to maximize a company's
creative output, to make
employees more collaborative.
Now in creating G Suite
our productivity solution,
we took the best of
our consumer products.
The ease of use, the intuitive
design, the scalability,
the intelligence built
into the products,
and we combined that
with a world class
set of enterprise features
around scalability,
performance, cost effectiveness.
And together, we've created
a very compelling solution
for companies.
But before I talk
about the product,
I first want to talk
about some research we do,
and the statistic 5%.
So we did a lot of
internal research
and external research a Google.
User studies looked
because the modern office
worker, the modern
professional to see
how they spend their time.
And the results were
pretty shocking.
So the typical modern
office place worker
today spends only
5% of their time
on creative work
and strategic work.
The other 95% of
their time is spent
on more mundane
activities that get
in the way of this other work.
This can include you
searching for files
and searching for
information, trying
to find the right
person in your company
to get a hold of to get the
right answer to a question.
It can involve things like
trying to set up a meeting
to get people together
in the same room,
or even trying to join
an audio conference
or a video conferencing meeting
and worrying about codes.
There are lots of
small things that
get in the way of the average
employee's typical workday.
Here's another example.
And a lot of
companies today, this
is the way that companies
collaborate around documents,
whether they're creating
a slide or presentation.
A team may have many
individuals, all
with numerous files on their
desktop for the same file,
slightly different versions,
emailing large attachments back
and forth, trying to
stay on the same page,
with the end result
of trying to create
that final, final version
that they can present.
This isn't a great
way of working,
and it's not very efficient.
When you look at how a G
Suite customer operates,
collaboration is central.
In Google Docs, one of our
most popular features today--
and we launched
this 10 years ago--
is the ability to
collaborate in real time.
So you can have a set of
multiple editors and authors
all working on a document--
whether it's from their
laptop or whether it's
from their mobile device--
they can edit in real time.
And they can see the
changes as they happen.
If they have comments,
if they have questions,
this can all be addressed
in real time making
the process much, much faster.
We pioneered this
and we continue
to extend this collaboration
throughout our products.
Another example is our
Team Drive feature which
we launched earlier this year.
So Drive is our cloud
based storage solution.
And we create a
concept of a team.
So now in Drive you can set up
a folder or a shared workspace
for your team where you
can store all the files
and information
related to that team.
So now every member of
your team always has
access to the latest files.
They can collaborate in all
these files in real time.
It doesn't matter
whether they're on the go
or whether they're
in the office,
they have access to this data.
We've combined this with
our Enterprise Feature
set such that Google Vault for
e-discovery and compliance.
And there's some great
security features built in.
Because the files
belong to the team,
if a member leaves a team or
someone leaves the company,
a team member
leaves the company,
you can revoke access
to these files,
but all the files stay
owned with the team.
So the rest the employees that
are left behind in the team
can continue working
at the same pace.
Another example of
collaboration in G Suite
is our Hangouts Meet video
conferencing solution.
Video conferencing is integrated
seamlessly into G Suite.
So it's very easy to
set up a meeting that
has videoconferencing support.
And whether an employee wants to
join from their mobile device,
whether they want to
join from the laptop,
or whether they're in a
meeting room with access
to video conferencing
hardware, with one click
they're seamlessly
out to the meeting.
Now at Google we see a big trend
where the future of meetings
is video conference moving
away from audio conference.
And there's been some
academic research
that's looked at audio
conferences in the workplace
environment.
And they found that people
who join in are simply
participating via phone,
are a lot less engaged
in the meeting,
they're much more
likely to be more multitasking,
and they're a lot less
likely to participate.
With videoconferencing
that changes dramatically.
People are more engaged.
Humans have a natural
instinct to want to work face
to face with individuals.
So it doesn't matter
whether you're
in different time zones
or different offices,
you can seamlessly collaborate
through video conferencing.
And that's collaboration.
I now want to turn your
attention to machine learning
and our visual intelligence,
and how that can
impact the productivity suite.
So at Google, we
have a huge focus
on machine learning and AI, and
building not into our products.
We want to create magical
product experiences
throughout G Suite.
Our focus is to automate
and let machines
take care of the mundane
and the mindless tasks,
and let humans really focus
on that creative work.
So we want to automate
this 95% of stuff
that gets in the way of
employees doing their best
work.
And I'm going to show you
some examples of how that
works throughout the products.
But Google is
uniquely positioned
to focus on AI due to
our infrastructure, which
you heard about earlier today.
We have a world class
set of data scientists
in machine learning
experts at Google.
And finally, we have a
massive amount of data
that we can use to
train our models.
So let's see how machine
learning works in the product
today.
A simple example is
Drive Quick Access.
So in our Drive
product, when someone
comes in the product for
the first time or they're
typically looking
to find a file.
And it used to be you'd have
to search to find that file.
Well, we created this feature
Quick Access, where now when
you come into Drive, you'll see
a set of five suggested files.
These are files we predict
you may want to open.
And we look at a variety
of different signals.
We look at the
time of day it is,
we look at what
meeting you are in,
based on what's
on your calendar,
we look at who you've been
collaborating with recently
on email or instant messaging.
And using all these
various signals,
our models will predict
which file you want to open.
Now this saves users a lot of
time and it's very accurate.
Over 40% of our
files stay in Drive
are opened through this
quick access feature.
And that number keeps
going up as our models get
better and better.
So a user on a
mobile device that's
trying to find
that file quickly,
can find it right away with
one click, start viewing it.
Really powerful.
Another example of machine
learning our products
is the Gmail Smart
Reply features.
Some of you may have
seen this before.
But now in Gmail on
your mobile device,
when you receive
an incoming email,
we'll use artificial
intelligence
to suggest three possible
responses for you
for that email.
Our studies show that a lot
of email communication today
is short form in
nature and can be
addressed with such a solution.
So in this example you see
behind me, a colleague of mine
has emailed me and asked me if
I've looked at the latest blog
files to analyze them.
With one click I can say,
yes, I'm working on it,
and get back to them.
Again, these are
small things, but they
add up over the
course of the day
and can save users a
lot of time, especially
in that mobile use case,
when you're on the go
and it's much more
difficult to type an answer.
And this model gets
better and better
as we have more data and
more usage of the product.
The third example I
want to give today
is for our Sheets product, which
is our cloud based spreadsheet
solution.
We launched a feature last
year called Explorer in Sheets.
Now spreadsheets are
the most common way
employees in your
enterprise will access data.
And our studies have found
that a third of your employees
aren't familiar with
formulas or don't really
know how to use formulas
and spreadsheets.
So it's very difficult for them
to get insights into the data.
So with our Explore future
we made it easy for anyone
to get data and insights
from their spreadsheet.
And the way we do that is
through natural language
processing, where
a user can simply
ask questions of the data and
we'll show them the answers.
So rather than
explain this, I think
the best way is to see it.
So I'd like to invite my
colleague Robert Kubis on stage
to give you a demonstration
of this feature.
Robert.
ROBERT KUBIS: Thank you, David.
[APPLAUSE]
[FRENCH] so I will switch
to English as well.
I assume everybody has seen
one of those, a spreadsheet
in one form or the other.
And tabular tables are
really, really powerful format
to structure your data.
So it sound maybe
a little scary,
but it's no surprise to you
that most companies are actually
relying on these kinds of data.
But only, as David mentioned
already, only about 30%
feel comfortable to get insights
out of their spreadsheet
by using formulas, charts,
and things like that.
So to enable more users to get
insights, actions, and charts
out of their spreadsheets,
we added the Explore button
to Sheets.
So when I click here, some magic
has happened behind the scenes.
And we give you some
actions and insights
on the right side,
as you can see here.
So we can see, for
instance for every increase
of 100 euro in revenue, our
profit increases by 68.5 euros.
So that's pretty nice.
As you can see, this spreadsheet
is about dessert sales.
So let's see if we
can find a nice chart.
I think the pie chart
here is probably pretty
appropriate for desserts.
So what we can do is we
can just with one click,
add the start into
our spreadsheet.
Now imagine what
you would have to do
if you would have to go to
the menu, select a chart,
find the appropriate chart,
select the columns that you
want to display in this chart.
So you can see that this just
saved you a whole lot of time.
Now if you don't find the
answer that you're looking for,
you can actually use
natural language processing
to see what data is
it in my spreadsheet.
So what I want
you to see here is
I want to look for the top
items sold in [INAUDIBLE]..
And as you can see here,
we have some answers.
It gives us also a formula.
And I'm not the most
proficient in Sheets,
but I probably could have
figured this formula out
with my favorite search
engine, and looking
how I can find and
do this calculation,
but it would have taken
me quite some time again,
and probably some
errors along the way.
So here you just type
in your question,
and you get the formula
presented to you
and can use it.
Now let's look at
something else.
I want to see who are
the best sales reps.
So we're also tracking
the sales rep here.
So our sales rep [INAUDIBLE].
And as you can see
here, Benjamin Button
is the best sales
rep [INAUDIBLE]..
And I can tweet this very
quickly and say in March
and see Mary Tyler Moore is
coming up very, very quickly.
So Benjamin should
watch his back.
So with Explore
we added for users
to get insights out of
their data very easily,
and using natural language
processing and machine learning
to do that.
With that, thank you very much.
Back to David.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID THACKER: Thanks Robert.
So that's one of the coolest
features in G Suite today.
That's a great example of
artificial intelligence.
And we're really just getting
started with these features.
Again, we want to help companies
maximize their creative output.
We want to democratize
access to data,
and this is an important
stepping stone in that.
So let's talk about customers
and how they're realizing value
from this.
So PWC, which is a large
global client services firm,
migrated to G Suite over
the last couple of years.
After they had
migrated to G Suite,
they ran an internal
study to look at
were their employees
actually saving more time.
And what they found
in these results
is that the average employee
was saving nine hours per week
due to some of these
time saving features
in G Suite and collaborative
nature of G Suite.
That's a lot of time savings.
When you think about nine
hours over the course
of the entire employee
base, that adds up.
That's more time to
focus on higher value
activities such as serving
and advising clients.
It's really a
powerful game changer.
So next let's talk
about how we've
made G Suite more extensible.
So in G Suite we
make it very easy
to plug in your own internal
workflow or third party
applications or data.
We have a set of tools
called App Maker Apps
Script and a set of APIs that
allow anyone in your company
to easily create applications
on top of G Suite,
leveraging G Suite data,
leveraging third party data,
and making it easy to integrate
workflow into the G Suite
experience.
An example of this is the
Gmail add on framework, which
we announced earlier this year.
This lets you create
an application
that can plug into Gmail.
So you can think of a lot of
situations where, for your m
you want to make it easy on
their workflow such as a sales
person having access
to their CRM data
plugged into G Suite, when
they are sending emails
to clients and prospects.
We're going to
continue to invest
in this to make it very easy.
We want to think of
G Suite as a platform
that you can build your
business on top of.
And finally, I want to talk
about of the administrative
controls in G Suite.
So G Suite, we have a set
of administrative features
to make you be able to optimize
G Suite for your enterprise
deployment, everything
from data loss prevention
to mobile device
management, we make
the admin controls very
simple and intuitive to use.
So that concludes my
presentation on G Suite.
I hope that gives
you an idea of how
it can transform the
way a company works,
helping you focus
on collaboration,
helping your employees
be more productive,
and helping them maximize
their creative output.
Earlier today you heard us
talking about optimizing
infrastructure and security.
I just spoke about
collaboration,
and how that can change
your company's culture.
Next we're going to
talk about accelerates.
And my colleague, Brad Calder
is going to come on stage
and talk to you about
how you can accelerate
your business by
focusing on what
you're uniquely suited for.
Brad.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRAD CALDER: Thanks, David.
And now I want to talk to you
about another reason for using
Google Cloud, which is to have
a partner that helps you manage
your data and drive
intelligence from your data
better than any other cloud.
You want to help
accelerate your business
to allow you to create
software faster, operate
faster, and find new insights
and opportunities faster
than ever before.
And given the vast
amount of data
that's being
generated every day,
it's a challenge to
extract meaning from data.
And it's even harder to make
critical decisions using it.
You shouldn't have
to worry about how
to configure your databases,
or have you correctly set up
your indexes for
efficient queries,
or have in manage your
infrastructure and in general.
Instead, you should let Google
Cloud take care of those issues
and take care of
the infrastructure,
while you instead focus on
finding new insights to drive
your business.
And nowhere does
Google's innovation show
up more sharply than
in our technology
for managing and
using your data,
both for creating applications
and for driving insights.
And we make this available to
you through Google Cloud's end
to end integrated manage
analytics platform.
Over the last year,
we've been building out
our platform capabilities.
And our platform now
ranges from storage
to data warehousing,
ingestion, PI cleaning, ETL,
batch and streaming data
pipelines, visualization,
and machine learning.
And it's extended by an
ecosystem of partners,
including Tableau, Looker,
Informatica Talend,
and many more advanced data
analytics leading companies.
Now the first thing you need
in order to manage your data
is a scalable and
available database.
But databases have always
had a fundamental limitation.
You either had to pick a
relational database that
has nice relational strong
consistency semantics,
but you have to
sacrifice scalability.
Or you could pick a
NoSQL database that
scales out horizontally, but you
have to sacrifice consistency.
And that creates a
significant pain and burden
for your developers.
And we've set out to solve
that fundamental problem
with our database
service Cloud Spanner.
Cloud Spanner is the first
and only relational database
that scales out horizontally,
providing strong consistency
at scale.
It scales horizontally
like a NoSQL database.
So we can handle pretty
much any transaction alone,
while still providing
the same SQL
semantics and
relational capabilities
and strong consistency of
a traditional database.
As an extra bonus, Spanner
can be globally distributed
without sacrificing consistency,
performance, or availability.
And on top of that, it's
a fully managed service.
So it's trivial to administer.
And it's battle tested.
We use Spanner for hundreds of
critical applications inside
of Google, including AdWords.
And now I'd like to
turn it over to Robert,
who will give us a look at
Cloud Spanner in action.
Robert.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: All right.
Hello everyone again.
So as Brad just
mentioned, Cloud Spanner
combines the reliability and
ease of use of an SQL database
with the horizontal scalability
of an NoSQL database.
But let me show you in action.
Now let's start at the beginning
at creating a database.
If you want to create a highly
scalable and available database
which is set up
for failover, you
need replication and charting
and things like that--
and it's quite a complex task.
It involves a lot of
configuration, even third party
and things like that.
Now even if you use a
managed database service,
setting this app for failover
and high availability
can be quite complex.
Now with Cloud Spanner, we
put all this into one screen.
As you can see here, I
just named the instance.
I choose a configuration.
In my case, I want to have your
[INAUDIBLE] regional instance.
I say how many nodes
I want to have.
I want to have 10 nodes here.
And I click Create.
And within seconds, I have
a database at my disposal.
Now what happens
behind the scene
is that we separate
compute and storage.
And with this we, enable Cloud
Spanner to scale horizontally,
but also we set it up for
high availability and disaster
recovery.
But let me show you a little
bit more real example.
Now what I have here is ticket
[INAUDIBLE] application.
Now imagine you are
in an event organizer,
and you want to sell tickets.
And you have a platform
where you basically
make these tickets available.
You can imagine that it's
really important that I
want to sell each ticket.
I don't want to
sell a ticket twice.
And even worse, I don't want
to charge any customer twice.
Now for this, it's obvious that
we need a transactional system.
And if this [INAUDIBLE],, if
this platform is globally,
then I need something that
this globally distributed.
Now to show you
that this is just
like a relational database, here
is the schema for this ticket
application that you just saw.
So I have a bunch of tables
that can be connected and joined
together.
You see columns in these
tables that are strongly typed.
Even some of these tables
are actually pretty large.
So the ticket tables has
almost two billion rows.
But there's no added
complexity from a NoSQL system.
So what you see here
is what you basically
are familiar with if you worked
with a traditional relational
database system.
Now while all this is running,
I can still run some queries
against this database.
So in this query here, I
just look at all the events
that are happening tonight
all over the world.
And how many seats are still
available for these events.
Now again, what you
don't see in here
is any edit complexability.
Now this query
that you see there,
is just the standard SQL query
with some addition for Spanner.
Now we understand that
your business changes
and your application develop.
And what you don't
want to have is
that your business
comes to a grinding
halt if you need to change
the schema for instance.
Now with Cloud Spanner we
have transactional consistent
capability to do
online schema changes.
So while your
workload is happening,
you can change your schema.
And if your app grows, if
you become really popular,
you want to add some capacity.
Now again, with a
traditional database system,
if you need to
scale up vertically,
you need to procure
a new machine.
You need to basically failover
to your new hardware, which
usually incurs some downtime.
Or if you have a
scale out system,
you have all this complexity
that I talked about
in the beginning.
Now with Cloud Spanner again,
we put all this into one screen.
So I go to Edit Instance.
I choose a new number of nodes--
42 in this case, because
it's always the right answer.
And I click Save.
And within seconds, I have this
new capacity at my disposal.
Now let's just recap.
With Cloud Spanner, you get
a highly reliable performant
and fully managed
database that can
be multi-regional with this
five nines of availability.
You can have it synchronously
globally replicated.
And you get all this
into operability
that you know from SQL and
[INAUDIBLE] transactions
with advanced features like
versioning, online schema
changes, and strong consistency.
So please try Cloud Spanner.
And I hope you enjoyed the demo.
Thanks.
Brad.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CALDER: Thanks.
Thanks Robert, for
that great demo.
Now in terms of using data, we
see our customers breaking down
data silos with the goal of
becoming a data driven company.
They want to make it faster
and easier for their employees
to mine data for insights.
And one of the most important
services to achieve that
is BigQuery.
BigQuery is a data
warehouse providing
fast interactive
analysis of data sets.
And those data sets can range
from terabytes to petabytes.
And you get your results
in seconds to minutes
instead of hours to days.
It allows you to quickly
find insights or virtually
any amount of data
that uses SQL,
it's encrypted, durable,
highly available.
And its scale and speed
are simply amazing.
Now we're seeing our customers
use our analytics products
in all sorts of ways, but there
are three primary use cases.
The first is migrating your
data warehouse to BigQuery.
We've seen hundreds of
companies make the move
to BigQuery in industries
ranging from manufacturing
to media to finance and health.
And second, we're
seeing customers
that need help in reducing the
cost and complexity of running
Hadoop and Spark clusters.
So to address this, we provide
a data prox service that
provides fully managed
Hadoop and Spark clusters
to easily run your workloads.
So this is a great
way of reducing
the cost and hassle of running
Hadoop and Spark yourself.
And the third use case
is we're seeing customers
that combine together
Pub/Sub plus Dataflow
plus BigQuery together to
analyzing streaming data
sets in real time for
applications such as data
mining, personalized
advertising,
and building
industrial IoT systems.
So as you can see,
we're unlocking
the power of your data with
end to end integrated managed
analytics, so you can focus on
finding those insights to drive
your business.
Now interactive analysis
is a great starting point.
But to fully take advantage
of that sea of data you have,
a company needs to leverage AI.
And we've been making
huge investments
in machine learning so that
every Google Cloud customer has
an on ramp into AI.
And we let you take advantage of
artificial intelligence in two
ways.
First, we're taking
the investment in AI
that Google is already doing for
its own products, like photos,
translate, and other
products, and making
those available to you via
very simple to use APIs.
So you don't have
to know anything
about artificial intelligence to
start adding those capabilities
to your applications.
Second, we're giving you the
tools to build your own models,
train them on your own data
sets, and run those models
on Google's amazing
infrastructure or anywhere
you want.
So let's start with Google's
fully train pre-built models.
We have a growing
number of models
that have already been trained
with its own domain expertise
and data sets.
And we've packaged
these APIs up so
that you can simply just drop
them into your application.
And these APIs act like
an intelligent component
that allows your application to
understand speech and photos,
translate text, and
parse natural languages.
And as I mentioned, these are
the same models that power
many applications
inside of Google,
such as Google
Photos, which allows
you to find a picture of almost
anything, Google SafeSearch,
which moderates for
inappropriate content,
in Google Translate, which
uses OCR to extract text
in multiple languages.
Today, we want to talk to you
about one more of these APIs
in a bit more detail, the
Cloud Video Intelligence API.
Now the most prevalent data
on the internet is video.
Hundreds of terabytes
and digital video
are being generated every hour.
And understanding the
contents of that data
has tremendous commercial value.
I'm excited to
invite Lee on stage
to show you the Video
Intelligence API in action.
Lee.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEE BOONSTRA: Thank your, Brad.
I'm actually very excited
today to give this live demo,
because the Video Intelligence
API is one of the APIs
that I really, really love.
And the reason for that
is because I am not
a data scientist.
I'm a developer.
So I can still make
use of machine learning
and do all these
fancy cool stuff.
The way how it works
it's a REST API.
So what I do is I can
upload a video in a bucket,
and then the Video
Intelligence API
will return the adjacent feet
with labels of everything
that it can see.
So then think about landmarks,
positions of faces, objects.
And it will give
that back with a time
stamp and also a
confidence level.
Now let me give you a demo.
What you see here is a video of
the International Women's Day.
And when I play it,
you see there are
lots of different shot changes.
You see here all
powerful women, you
see women in politics,
women in sports.
You see infants.
You see all kinds of shots here.
Now imagine that I
would be a company,
and I would like to categorize
this video for my websites.
Then I would have to
watch a full video.
And then I need to write down
all the labels of everything
that I can see.
Now you can imagine if
I would blink my eye,
I probably would
miss a shot here.
And therefore, we let
the machine do this.
That's what we did
here in this demo.
You can see here all the
labels the machine learning
Video Intelligence saw.
So for example, I see
here a football player.
And you see it also
returns a time frame.
There it is.
And here is a [INAUDIBLE].
That's pretty amazing, I think.
It's also the other way around.
So let's say that I have
terabytes of video data,
and let's say I
write a blog post.
And with my blog post I
would like to show a video.
Let's say I write a blog
post about basketball.
It's really nice that
the Video Intelligence
API, because it is
labeled everything,
that I immediately can
find all the videos that
contain basketball.
And to let me show
you a demo of that.
So here I have they have
my video application again.
And I search for basketball.
Let me search for
basketball here.
And there you go.
You see two videos in my
whole full video database
that contains basketball.
And as you can see,
the first video
contains lots of shots
about basketball.
And you see that it
is on every key frame.
But I actually also had
another video about basketball,
which was just one single shot.
Let's see if I
can go back there.
And I would have never
known that that also
contained basketball.
So with the Video
Intelligence API,
it makes it very easy to
understand your video library.
And with that said, I'd like
to hand it over to Brad.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CALDER: Thanks, Lee.
Thanks for the great demo.
Of course, that's all great.
But what about leveraging
your own data sets
for artificial intelligence?
To achieve this, we
give you the ability
to train your own data sets
using Google Cloud's Machine
Learning Engine.
Cloud ML Engine helps
you train your model
using a custom TensorFlow
graph for any ML use
case using CPUs or GPUs.
You can easily train your
model using TensorFlow focusing
on the creativity
of your solution,
and leave the
infrastructure to us.
And when you're done, you
can publish those models
to make predictions
for your application,
using simple API calls to
put that training to use.
So TensorFlow is an
important part of this.
So what is TensorFlow?
TensorFlow is an open source
machine learning library
originally developed by Google.
And it's used to
create and train
your machine learning models.
And the uptake of TensorFlow
has been phenomenal.
TensorFlow is the most
popular open source machine
learning project on
GitHub, with contributions
coming from many
companies, not just Google.
And in addition to being
a powerful framework,
TensorFlow was designed
to run anywhere.
You can run TensorFlow
on our Cloud ML Engine,
as I just described,
or you can run them
on your own servers in
your own data centers,
or anywhere you want,
like mobile devices.
Now in order to
accelerate your business,
this typically means building
applications and continuously
improving them to take advantage
of your data, the insights
you've derived, as well as
your machine learning models.
This means creating software
to make important long term
decisions, as well as real
time decisions like what
offer to put in
front of a customer
before they potentially
leave your website.
Now for your
applications, you want
to focus on creating
great software,
not managing infrastructure.
And the key to being able
to create great software
is to unleash your
developers from the burdens
of infrastructure.
Today, way too
much developer time
is spent on configuring and
managing hardware and software
infrastructure.
This results in your
developers spending their time
as operators and not
being developers.
So at Google, our
goal is to allow
you to accelerate your software
management by making it easy
for you to build your
applications at global scale
without needing to know about
or understand the infrastructure
details.
Because at the end of the
day, you want your developers
to be writing code not
patching, operating,
and scaling infrastructure.
And that's what your
developers want too.
So in Google Cloud
we enable this
by offering you server
lists and container
solutions at scale
with different options
to meet your different needs.
This is provided by the
three services shown here,
Container Engine, App
Engine, and Cloud Functions.
Container Engine is our
fully managed Kubernetes
as a service.
It's the fastest way to take
advantage of Kubernetes.
And lets you scale
docker containers easily
in production.
And since Google
started Kubernetes,
it's no accident that GCP
provides the easiest way
to run Kubernetes in the cloud.
Container Engine uses the same
open source Kubernetes code
base to orchestrate
your application,
allowing you to easily
leverage the rest of GCP
for running your service.
And Container Engine handles
all the infrastructure details.
It schedules and manages your
containers automatically,
letting you focus
on your application.
And as a proof point, most of
you will probably remember,
Niantic used Container
Engine to launch
their blockbuster
Pokemon Go game.
That game famously scaled
to many millions of users
across dozens of countries
over a period of days.
And they reached a capacity
in scale that was 50 times--
yes, 50 times their
pre-launch estimates.
So it was quite an amazing
launch and product.
Now some application
developers don't even
want to think about clusters.
They want to upload their
focus even a notch higher
to what the industry
is calling server-less.
Server-less means that there
is no cluster, node nodes,
no pods to think about.
All you see when you
implement, deploy, and manage
your application are
application level constructs.
In addition, another
benefit of server-less
is that when your application
consumes little or no resources
when there's zero load, it can
then quickly start up and scale
out as load demands it.
And Google Cloud's App
Engine pioneered server-less,
empowering applications to
scale from serving one request
today to quickly
scaling millions
of requests per second.
And App Engine
manages everything
on behalf shown here.
You just add your
application code.
And this is really liberated
the developers and big companies
like Snapchat, Home
Depot, Philips Lightning,
and other companies, allowing
them to achieve incredible time
to scale, market, and agility.
Now if you actually just
want to run some functions
in the cloud, we have
you covered there
with Cloud Functions.
With Cloud Functions,
a developer
can connect existing
cloud services,
or build brand new ones in
an entirely server-less way.
With Cloud Functions,
you only pay
for the resources consumed while
your functions are running.
Billion occurs at the
nearest 1/10 of a second.
And Cloud Functions
can be triggered
by a growing list of events
generated by GCP services.
Essentially, we've
designed Cloud Functions
so it's easy to extend GCP
to fit your business needs.
In addition, you can use
Cloud Functions from Firebase
as well.
This makes it very easy
for mobile developers
to add server side
extensions without having
to learn about, configure,
or deal with servers.
And there are many use
cases for Cloud Functions,
from the triggering
of examination
of files that have been recently
uploaded to your cloud storage,
to triggering events
that are in your logs,
to reacting to
actions your users are
taking in your applications.
And with that, I'm now
pleased to introduce Thomas
to talk about how Dailymotion
is using Google Cloud to improve
and accelerate their services.
Thomas.
[APPLAUSE]
THOMAS ACHACHE: Thank
you very much, Brad.
Thank you very much.
Hello, everyone.
I am Tomas Achache.
I'm the vice president
of DADA at Dailymotion.
Today we're going to be speaking
of Dailymotion, of course,
and also about the ways that
we use Google Cloud to power
our applications and what
difference it makes to us.
So Dailymotion is one of
the leading video platform
in the world.
We have three billion
views and 300 million users
per month on a catalog
of 150 million videos.
We have offices in
five continents,
and we are translating
in 20 languages.
In terms of data, we receive
3.5 billion events per day.
But more importantly,
recently, we
have been through a complete
overhaul of our customer
experience.
We have redesigned everything
from bottom to floor,
and we have relied heavily on
machine learning to do that.
We have of course, developed
classical algorithms
for trending videos,
popular channels,
but we have also done
more special things
like semantic
notation, which means
that we try not only to
understand what objects
were recognized in the video.
But to understand what
the topic of the video
was about, on ontology
of 25 million topics.
So for instance, you
can see any video
that we have on bitcoin
or [INAUDIBLE] recently.
This is very important
to us, because it
helps us to detect what are the
trending topics at the moment.
This helps our users to have
a topic-based navigation
to see more videos
on the same topic.
And it also helps us to
understand better what
our users are interested about.
We also host a music
content for universal music.
And so we have also put
in place neural nets
to analyze the music
track of our music videos
so that they can use them in the
representation, a [INAUDIBLE]
representation of
what they contain.
And that helps us to
build smart playlists
to help our users discover
more interesting content
that is related to the current
clips they're watching.
Now to come back on GCP
and how we use it, for us
GCP is really helping us
to increase our speed.
Obviously, our speed
of development,
but also it helps us
building better products
because it allows
us to have our data
available to our
algorithms faster.
So on the first point,
on development time,
so our apps send 3.5
billion events a day.
And we have developed
a pipeline as it
goes through Pub/Sub DataFlow,
and BigQuery in real time.
In terms of development speed,
this took us only two weeks
to implement.
Because we could find on
GCP all the basic bricks
that allowed us to set it up.
But beyond the speed at
which we have developed
this, what matters even
more is that now whenever
we are thinking
about a new product,
instead of trying
to think about OK,
what architecture
we're going to use?
What stack?
What technologies are
we going to set up?
How are we going
to maintain them?
The first question we ask
is can we do this with SQL?
Because BigQuery
is so fast that it
can leverage all
the amount of data
that we send to it in
a matter of seconds.
And so it's fast enough for most
of our production applications.
And so with this
pipeline, we are
able to address issues like
how many concurrent users do
we have on a given live video?
We are able to build very
simple recommender algorithms.
And we also provide
real time analytics
to the partners [INAUDIBLE]
videos on the platform.
And it's really helping us
to go faster in our backlog,
and to release more
features for all our users.
So having the data
available fast
can bring marginal improvements
for some algorithms
like recommendation.
For some other algorithms,
it is make or break.
For instance, we have recently
developed a new algorithm
to detect fraudulent
impressions on the platform.
And we used to base it on
old Hadoop pipelines that
took seven hours for
that data to be made
available to the algorithm.
When we switched to BigQuery
real time pipelines that I just
showed, we were able to
intercept 10 times more--
10 times more
fraudulent impressions,
because we're more reactive.
And so to summarize my
message, the accelerations
that the cloud provides
us is real at Dailymotion.
It impacts our development
speed and the quality
of our products.
And so for us, it
is an investment
in what our customers see.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CALDER: Thank you, Thomas.
It's great to see the
impressive results that you've
attained using our cloud.
And now I'd like to
introduce Francois
who explain how the
cloud is transforming
in the historic retail brand.
Francois.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
FRANCOIS NGUYEN: Thank you.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CALDER: Thanks, Francois.
Thank you.
It's amazing to see such a
great transformation so quickly
using Google Cloud.
And now I'd like to thank you.
I've had the privilege of being
able to share with you how
Google Cloud can accelerate your
business by helping effectively
manage your data, drive
intelligence from your data,
add artificial intelligence
to your applications,
and how to accelerate building
and running those applications.
And to talk about Google
Cloud as a partner,
let me call on stage Sam
Ramji, Vice President
of product management.
Sam.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAM RAMJI: Hello everyone.
I hope you're doing great.
It's an honor to be here today.
At Google, we believe
that customers
are looking for something
new, a new kind of business
relationship, a new suite
of technologies, a new place
to do things in a new way, and
a partner with a new approach.
Our support of this
new kind of partnership
starts with openness.
I'm going to focus
on two things.
First, support for
what you want to run
and for what you have to run.
Second, flexible customer
friendly pricing.
It's about putting you in
control of your technology.
So our customers are
telling us that business
is demanding more innovation,
faster, on a smaller budget.
And somehow IT has
to deliver all this.
We believe that you can
support your existing workloads
for less money, allowing
you to innovate.
So at Google we've learned
that your freedom to innovate
requires not having to
worry about our costs.
That's what we do internally.
That's why innovation
velocity is so high.
We free developers from
worrying about the trappings
of infrastructure, as
well as simplifying
what it's going to cost.
So the first step is
understanding and planning
your migration.
We're seeing global CIOs
migrating from their data
centers to save costs.
But there are many
benefits beyond cost.
Better security,
better reliability,
and access to some
amazing innovations
that live inside
of Google Cloud.
Ideally, you want to migrate
while changing as little
as possible.
You want to minimize
the change so
that you minimize the chance
of breaking your applications.
Now later you'll refactor
to use manage services,
like Cloud Spanner or
our machine learning,
or the DLP APIs.
So you want to migrate,
then modernize.
Our job is to make it as
easy with both technology
and people.
So you probably know
that Google Cloud
is a great place for Linux
and open source development.
We're making it a great
place for Windows developers
and IT pros as well.
We have support
for people, images
of many versions of Windows
Server, as well as SQL Server.
We also support Active
Directory in the cloud,
so that you can extend your
on premises Active Directory
domain controllers.
For developers, are goal is
to meet them where they are,
without requiring
significant change.
So you can use Visual Studio
to deploy .net applications
and manage cloud resources.
We've also created hundreds
of PowerShell commandlets
in the Cloud SDK for
administrating your cloud
projects.
To help with your
journey, we also
have an amazing
set of engineers.
When I think about
Google Cloud, I
think about our engineer
to engineer relationship.
First, our sales engineers
and our solution architects
will help you
understand Google Cloud,
and get quickly
get on to getting
your applications deployed.
Our support teams are backed
by our product engineering
organization in
case you need help.
Ulku Rowe talked to you earlier.
She is from the
office of the CTO.
They work directly
with customers
who are taking on massive
efforts that require industry
expertise in areas like
manufacturing, energy, health
care, or financial services.
We have customer
reliability engineers
who use Google's best
practices for creating
billion users scale applications
and keeping them running,
like Gmail, Search, and ads.
They'll help your team
ensure reliability, even
in the most extreme conditions.
And because we
participate directly
in open source
communities, we can often
help you with your
questions or your issues
in deploying open source
stacks, whether on premises
or in Google Cloud.
So this is how we
helped Evernote migrate
their entire software
infrastructure from on premises
to Google Cloud in just 89 days.
So you might ask, what's the
best test for minimal friction
when migrating?
I think the best test
is zero downtime.
It may sound
impossible, but we did
it working closely with Evernote
working engineer to engineer.
200 million of their customers
moved to Google Cloud
with no change in
service and no downtime.
Lush is another great example.
In 22 days we moved 17 web
sites and applications,
including core databases.
Users, orders,
products, and content.
These are mission critical.
They moved databases with sizes
ranging from a few gigabytes
to 100 gigabytes
to Google Cloud.
And our engineer to
engineer approach
made the migration process
fast and predictable.
You dump data into
cloud storage,
and restore it into Cloud SQL.
You shift from a
vertical scaling
to a horizontal
scaling architecture.
To get there, let's
talk about costs.
So clouds are supposed to
be elastic and free you
from Capex and from
capacity planning.
Now some cloud
providers forced you
to pay upfront for a
three year commitment
in order to get the best price.
But if you have to buy a
virtual machine for three years,
how is that actually better
than buying your own server
for three years?
We think it's not.
A recent state of
the cloud report
showed that cloud users waste
45% of their bill on resources
that they don't use.
Now that waste is
caused by many factors.
First, three year leases force
you to predict your future
perfectly.
And really none of us are
capable of doing that.
So you end up with
stranded resources.
Second, just like with
on premises servers,
you're forced to buy fixed
machine configurations
with particular amounts
of RAM, storage, and CPU.
So you end up paying for
a machine over time that
is too big for you
in some dimensions
and too small in others.
And you pay for the full
hour, even if your test only
takes 10 minutes.
So you're paying for compute
time that you're not using.
This all adds up to 45%
unnecessary expenditure.
We think that there's a
better and cheaper way
to run your cloud.
We believe that we've
solved all three
of these sources
of waste, in fact.
So first, automatic
sustained use discounts
that are applied to give you
savings without any long term
agreement.
As soon as you use a VM
for more than a week,
you will see savings.
If you use a VM for
an entire month,
you will get a 30% discount.
But you're still free to stop
using that VM at any time.
Sustained use discounts,
as we like to say,
bring the cloud back into cloud.
Change your mind at any time
and still get great prices.
It should be on demand.
Second, you don't need to accept
a fixed machine configurations.
As we say, why would
you want to have
only virtual machines whose
shape comes in powers of two?
With other providers,
if your applications
need 20 cores and
maybe 50 gigs of RAM,
you might have to buy a 40
core, 160 gigabyte machine.
You could literally be
paying for more than double
the resources you need.
But with Google,
Custom Machines let
you dial in exactly the
configuration you need.
You pay for exactly the
resources that you use.
These are so popular
that over 20%
of all the core hours
operating on Google Cloud
are custom machines.
They're so popular,
what we decided to do
was help you save more
money with our rightsizing
recommendations.
So we apply ML algorithms
internally, and prompt you
with alerts where we think
that you could save money,
because you're mean and
even your peak utilization
of that machine
is lower than what
you specified for the machine.
So we try to suggest the
best virtual machine size
to proactively save you money.
So finally, and this
is pretty exciting,
pay only for what you
use by the second.
So Google is the first to
offer per second billing
for all services.
If you use a VM for 90 seconds,
you pay for 90 seconds.
This is available and active in
Google Cloud today right now.
So Google Cloud is elastic.
You only buy what you
need, only when you use it,
and you automatically get
discounts for sustained usage.
We think this makes it
much more simple for you.
We even alert you when you
appear to be wasting resources.
When you put all
of this together,
we save our customers
on an average 60%
relative to what they
pay on other clouds.
With that, it's
my great pleasure
to introduce Christophe
Defayet from Amadeus
to talk about his experience of
this new kind of relationship.
Christophe.
[APPLAUSE] [MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHE DAFAYET: Thank you.
A lot of what's Sam mentioned
was [INAUDIBLE] to me
because we do use many of
the feature you mention.
So now let's transition
mostly back to France.
My slides we meet in English,
but je parlez francais.
[APPLAUSE] [SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]
BRAD CALDER: So to
close out the morning,
let me invite Sebastien
Malotte to come back to stage.
[APPLAUSE]
SEBASTIEN MALOTTE: Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
[APPLAUSE]